I grew up in Newport Beach California
where for those of you who've seen
housewives or watch The OC it is placed
with a lot of beautiful people a lot of
affluent growing up I felt the
expectation of me was to be a success by
getting married and having really cute
babies and that was my number one job at
24 I did exactly that got engaged it
took me a while to really understand and
navigate that I could go against the
grain on that expectation ended up
calling my wedding off two weeks before
realized it wasn't the right path for me
fast-forward 10 years I'm still haven't
met the right person I've been excited
about my career excited about traveling
dating doing all sorts of things that
somebody in their 30s is not expected to
want to still do all these things I
never thought I would be somebody who
would be interested in freezing my eggs
and then my dad passed away unexpectedly
and that changed everything it made me
realize how important family is and
although today I may not see myself
having kids in this moment maybe I'll
want that later I would love to keep my
options open when I went to the doctor's
office for just an informational visit
just to learn you know a little bit more
about the process they ran some
preliminary tests and I had just started
my period which is the ideal time to
start the hormone therapy and start this
process so with the test results
provided those were okay which they were
they wanted to go ahead and start my
hormone therapy if I was on board I was
actually a little bit more excited about
it then I thought that I would be and
through the tests we did my first
ultrasound he showed me these are your
ovaries this is where the baby would
grow and it was the first time in my
entire life that I felt any kind of ping
of maternal stuff it just so happened to
be that now is the time and my body was
ready why not so when I started this
process I had an entire table full of
hormones
the purpose of the hormone injections is
to basically it's like steroids for your
eggs as a natural woman you drop one egg
a month but because of these hormones
you have tons of them and then you want
them to get big and fat and juicy so
that they can see them when they're
going in to harvest the egg
then it's the last 30 hours when they
say okay now you're ready to go that's
when you get the trigger shot and that
was pretty intense
so pull down the pants look in the
mirror and they teach you you have to
inject yourself so hard that it goes
behind the muscle and they tell you as
you check it if there's blood that it's
not far enough so you have to push it
out and do it again so thank God I got
it on the first try so the trigger shot
then will start the process of getting
the follicles ready and the eggs ready
for retrieval 30 hours later show up at
the doctor's office and they put me to
sleep they go up inside me and they you
know broke the follicles to suction out
the eggs and the eggs are immediately
frozen the process itself is very quick
the procedure took maybe 20 minutes the
doctor predicted that I would have 12 to
14 eggs at the end of this process that
they could harvest out of those eggs
they say one out of every four count on
those being viable I ended up having 20
eggs which was a lot more than they
expected and about 48 hours after the
surgery I immediately just puffed out
with the 20 follicles that my body had
created as the doctor goes in there to
retrieve the eggs they basically
puncture each follicle and then suck out
this little microscopic egg well all
that fluid around that egg now has to go
somewhere it was the most frustrating
time ever being a woman that it has
curves and has always thought it been
conscious of what am i eating and my
exercising and am i losing weight am i
gaining weight I was put in a position
where my body was constantly gaining
weight even though I wasn't eating I
wasn't drinking I couldn't even have
water and yet I'm gaining weight
it sucked it was absolutely terrible for
some people freezing your eggs might be
easy lickety-split no problem I'm back
to work the next day for me personally
it was not that everybody's unique their
situations are unique but I think it's
important to know all sides so you can
make an educated decision they
on all perspectives when I grew up I
never felt I could be respected for
wanting to be the person that I truly am
so whatever you choose let it be your
choice what's right for you not what the
expectations were review growing up or
what your parents want you to do what
your boyfriend wants you to do your
husband its you have to have the best
relationship with yourself